un edificio de gobierno en llamas son
imágenes del viernes en trípoli y
segunda ciudad de líbano una nueva
extensión del cierre hasta el 8 de
febrero despertó la ira de los libaneses
el país tiene a más del 50 por ciento de
la población bajo el umbral de la
pobreza la gente exige su derecho quiere
comer la gente tiene hambre todos
tenemos hambre aquellos que tengan honor
deberían unirse de medio oriente hasta
américa latina en perú lima y otras
nueve regiones se encuentran en un
cierre estricto hasta el 15 de febrero
la desesperación aumenta como expresión
manifestantes que chocaron con la
policía el jueves en la capital rozando
el ancho por comer y vete vamos a vivir
el kobe 19 ha costado ya más de 2
millones de vidas pero también 255
millones de empleos en el mundo según la
organización internacional del trabajo
de sus pizzas ha sido la crisis más
severa para el mundo del trabajo desde
la gran depresión de la década de 1930
efectos económicos pero también
psicológicos en francia- expertos
aseguran que la depresión ha aumentado
en un 30% y la ansiedad en un 20% se
estima que una de cada dos personas con
kobe tendrá síntomas psiquiátricos o
psicológicos en el futuro gonzález sinde
está a punto de cumplirse un año donde
ha predominado el aislamiento social
cada vez surgen más protestas y
hartazgos como en ciudad del cabo
sudáfrica donde este sábado bañistas
entraron al mar para protestar contra
las medidas de confinamiento
y recreación pero también fiesta eso es
lo que pedían los jóvenes de nantes en
francia en un improvisado concierto de
techno en el que reivindicaban el que
consideran su derecho a festejar